on redoutait le pire et le pire n'est
pas arrivé en tout cas pour le moment
cet hôpital d'abidjan s'était préparé à
un afflux
mais les lits sont toujours vides une
des explications avancées que le fait
que la population soit jeune l'afrique à
près de deux tiers de sa population qui
a moins 45 ans donc de toute façon on se
doute bien que la gravité est moindre
dans sur une population plus jeune et
puis selon certains la réaction rapide
des pays pour prévenir la contagion
pourrait aussi expliquer ces chiffres
bas car le continent n'en est pas à sa
première épidémie pas frais de santé has
et les plaques soi de pouvoir rapidement
réagi et la population sont habitués aux
femmes le phase de prévention
l'afrique du sud est le pays le plus
touché avec plus de 12000 cas et 238
morts mais ce qui inquiète c'est
l'impact du confinement sur la
population et la fnc lab
la vie est dure dit il nous avons faim
aujourd'hui ils étaient plus de dix
mille personnes à faire la queue pour
recevoir de la nourriture au nom de
bwana bolide imao l'ovalie je ne peux
rien faire dit elle personne ne
travaille
j'étais capable de survivre avec les
petits travaux mais plus maintenant
la plupart sur vivait au jour le jour en
vendant des biens ou de la nourriture
dans la rue mais ce n'est plus possible
face à cette détresse sociale le
gouvernement sud africain a débloqué
plus de 36 milliards de dollars
mais ce ne serait pas assez spipoll à
angry robot
ces gens là ont faim dit il ce sont les
pauvres et plus vulnérables avec les ong
on a décidé de leur donner de la
nourriture de base et des masques leur
confinement fait beaucoup plus mal à
l'afrique le virus parce que ça prive
les africains de leur pain quotidien
parce que la plupart du temps ça l'est
en afrique sur l'économie est très
exposé et les gens sautent au quotidien
pour aller vendre 8 et ramener de
l'argent et ramener les denrées de
première nécessité au quotidien amina
gerba organise une levée de fonds avec
la diaspora africaine au cas où le virus
frappe fort sur le continent les plus
nantis les commerces sont aussi affectés
sur le continent ce restaurant prisé de
johannesbourg a vu sa clientèle de
déserter m'a fait trop chaud
blues in russia ma peur c'est de faire
mais je craint de perdre mon restaurant
dit il si ça continue pendant des mois
que va-t-il arriver à mes employés ont
des familles et moi aussi
qu'allons nous faire les craintes sont
universels pour l'instant à l'afrique
résiste mieux que prévu à la pandémie et
le continent continue à faire face à un
défi de taille
la malaria qui a fait plus de 300000
morts en 2018
ici aux abois déguerpissent radio canada
montréal